Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du was? Ampeln gibt's auch ohne Gelb.
Ich kenne nur Ampeln ohne Gelb, ich bin Radfahrer.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer vierhundertundzweiundvierzig vom zehnten zehnten zweiundzwanzig. Schöne Zahlen sind das. Ja und äh die Welt ist in Bewegung weiterhin,
Rollen schnurstracks auf die goldenen Zwanziger zu übrigens. Falls dir das noch nicht aufgefallen ist.
Also dat Ding ist echt langsam durch.
Na wieso kommt man muss ja auch ein bisschen einen Spannungsbogen aufbauen, ne,
Sonst hast du, hast du am Schluss einfach nicht den Comic Relief, so das ähm gehört einfach dazu.
Okay, ja, bin ich sehr gespannt.
Ist ein bisschen dramatisch, aber na ja.
Jeden Fall irre goldene Zwanziger, die sich da jetzt langsam ankündigen Tim. Also ich.
Crazy. Crazy. Crazy auf jeden Fall. So ist das.
So, was haben wir erlebt? Wir machen, wir machen wir können ja jetzt schon sagen, wir werden sehr bald wieder eine Sendung machen, aber wir dachten uns, wir machen heute auch schon mal eine.
Genau mal abräumen, was noch so äh rumliegt damit ihr auch äh unterhalten seid so. Wir hatten ja auch ein paar mal mehr als eine Woche gebraucht. Jetzt äh kriegt ihr es halt extra.
Ist wieder Winter, jetzt ist es jetzt führen wir uns wieder einsam. Jetzt zieht es uns wieder zueinander und.
Ja und ich muss mir ja bald einen dicken Pulli im Studio anziehen irgendwie oder äh ich drücke dir doch nochmal auf.
Für Podcasts ja nur damit die Rechner warm werden.
Funktioniert ja bei diesen modernen Geräten auch nicht mehr so richtig.
Ja, das stimmt.
Bei dir? Also ich habe jetzt hier siebzehn ,5 Grad. Das geht grad noch so.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie warm ist, ähm weil die Heizhermostate, was also äh nicht realistische Werte anzeigen, aber äh ich heize nicht.
Gedöns bringt einen auch nicht weiter in der Krise.
Doch heizt, heizt genauso. Ich finde ein analoges Thermostat, also.
Schon, also ich ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange das wirklich ohne Heizen funktioniert, aber ähm,
Was ich jetzt mal gebastelt habe, ist tatsächlich so konsequente Umsetzung von presence, also dass halt auch so andere Spielereien, die,
notwendig sind, ausgehen oder auch kleinere Lichter, die halt normalerweise einfach um angehen, wenn's dunkel wird, dass die halt auch äh nur an sind, wenn ich da bin.
Dekofrei durch Weihnachten durch.
Wenn ich da bin, will ich die Deko schon haben. Ich muss ja was sehen. Also ich muss ja schon was sehen. Jetzt komm.
Dann macht man Putzlicht an.
Ja, nee, ich mache halt ein kleines bisschen hier. LED so.
Na ja.
Ist wirklich sehr schön alles.
Frieren für den Weltfrieden auf jeden Fall. So was haben wir denn auf der Uhr heute? Gar nicht so viel.
Wir haben natürlich natürlich das äh Böhmermann Thema.
Hat äh eine Sendung gemacht, haben wahrscheinlich die meisten auch gesehen ähm einige Leute darauf auf Twitter sich gefreut, dass wir uns damit auseinandersetzen werden und
ja ich sage mal so, ich glaube, ich äh komme da zum leicht differenzierteren Schluss zu, aber,
Die Kurzgeschichte.
Hm.
Die Kurzgeschichte äh oder die kurze Zusammenfassung. Ich will jetzt gleich gleich gehe ich da im Detail drauf ein. Ähm.
Der Präsident des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik pflegt Kontakte zu einem Verein, den er selber gegründet hat, welcher wiederum gute Kontakte zu russischen,
ja Institutionen im weitesten Sinne pflegt und äh das hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass in zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, heute ist ja Montag ähm,
eigentlich in fast allen großen Medien kolportiert wird, dass man sich,
Bundesinnenministerium darüber Gedanken macht, wie man den BSI-Präsidenten absetzen kann. Was nicht so ohne Weiteres geht, denn dieser Posten ist ein,
Karrierebeamter,
Ja? Wenn man den loswerden möchte, wenn sie sagen jetzt nicht irgendwie massive Verfehlungen hatte äh wirst du die nicht los, ist beamtet. Das heißt, du musst dem jetzt eben, du musst jetzt eine andere Verwendung für den finden.
Ähm kannst ihn also nicht irgendwie so in einstweiligen Ruhestand schicken oder so
Also es wird gar nicht so einfach, wenn wenn man das denn durchziehen möchte, aber ich würde sagen, nach dieser Sendung
halte ich die Wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt schon für sehr groß, dass das passieren wird, weil er sich weil sag mal, es wird schwer, sich nach von dieser Sendung zu erholen. Also ähm.
Von den für alle Schönbrunnen.
Von unserer Sendung.
Von der Böhmermannssendung. Wir wir erholen uns ja von innerhalb von 48 Stunden von so einer Sendung, aber,
ne also genau, worum geht es? Also es gibt mehrere äh Dinge, die da zusammenkommen und die auch bei Böhmermann, ich sage mal so ein bisschen
vielleicht äh also du musst ich habe die Sendung auch zweimal geschaut, weil ich beim ersten Mal irgendwie dachte so nicht mitbekommen, da ist doch irgendwie überhaupt nix. Als ich das zweite Mal geguckt habe, habe ich mir gedacht, so na ja der ist ja jetzt ja wirklich überhaupt nix, aber okay, fangen wir mal an. Es,
um den Cybersicherheitsrat EV. Ein Verein, ja der heißt,
Also ist der Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland EV,
Und der heißt genauso, es gibt auch einen Cybersicherheitsrat, nämlich den nationalen Cybersicherheitsrat. Der wurde am 23. Februar 2011 von der deutschen Bundesregierung gegründet.
Der etwas über ein Jahr später, nämlich im August zwanzig12,
wird der Cybersicherheitsrat EV gegründet. Was in meinen Augen schon,
Also du kannst doch nicht einfach Vereine gründen, die so heißen wie Gremien der deutschen Bundesregierung, oder? Weil sonst können wir ja auch einfach jetzt hier den Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik EV gründen.
Oder Bundesregierung EV ja.
Ja, Bundeskanzleramt EV. So, Vorsitzende des Bundeskanzleramt EV. Also das ist ja schon mal.
Das wäre der einfachste Weg, sozusagen Kanzler zu werden. Also das ist jetzt ah da kommen wir dann doch Ideen. Na gut.
Also das ist schon wirklich ein bisschen schwach, ja und das ist halt ein,
Es ist ein Lobbyverein durch und durch, ja? Nie irgendwas Vernünftiges gemacht, ganz klar. Gegründet von also Gründungspräsident ist Arne Schönbohm.
2012 gründet der also diesen Lobbyverein. Das ist vier Jahre vor seiner äh vor seiner.
Aufnahme als Präsident des äh Bundesamtes versichert in der Informationstechnik und da hat er dann auch den Vorsitz in diesem Verein, der absoluter äh Quatschverein ist
und der so nie hätte existieren dürfen, weil der hätte hätte hätte die Bundesregierung verklagen sollen, statt den den Gründungspräsidenten dieses Vereines äh zum BSI-Präsidenten zu machen, aber,
Das Gegenteil war der Fall, ja und er legt dann seinen Vorsitz nieder. Das heißt, er hat seit äh irgendwie Februar zwanzig16 oder wann ist er BSI-Präsident geworden auf Vorschlag von,
Thomas de Maizire, dem damaligen Bundesinnenminister und Schönmum legt dann den Vorsitz in diesem Verein nieder, aber der Verein,
hat es tatsächlich hat einen sehr großen Erfolg gehabt,
viele Unternehmen, die dort Mitglied sind, irgendwie Automobilzulieferer, PWC, EY, Kommerzbank, ähm
Das Bundesgesundheitsministerium. Alle wollten irgendwie im Cybersicherheitsrat sein, weil sie irgendwie meinten, ja hier, dann haben wir, ne, dann das da damit kann man sich ja auch schmücken, ne,
also ist ja schon,
relativ geschickt angelegt so ein Verein, der irgendwie heißt wie ein wie ein wie eigentlich wie so ein nationales Gremium, was aber eigentlich nicht ist, ne und dann,
schmücken sich ja auch Unternehmen gerne damit in Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland. Das das ist doch mal was.
Ne? Da hat man was eigenes so und.
Kann man seine Zukunft mit planen.
So was was passiert danach? Also schön mitm Tritt zurück,
oder gibt den Posten da auf und es übernimmt Hans Wilhelm Dünn der war schon unter schönen Boom Vize und nach seinem Rücktritt dann eben Präsident dieses Vereins und,
der äh geboren in Köln hat irgendwie Verwaltungswissenschaften in Potsdam studiert, war dann
Referent im Wirtschaftsministerium von Brandenburg und dann auch irgendwie in der Potsdamer Stadtverordnetenversammlung, also ebenso Lokalpolitiker ebenso, ne?
Außerdem, jetzt kommt's der Gag, Geschäftspartner von Arne Schönbum, nämlich in der BSS-Booke oder,
Share Services AG. Ja? Die haben nämlich zusammen 2008 ein Unternehmen gegründet,
Ja, also und genau dieses Unternehmen, ja? So und.
Der dünn war bis 20019 Vorstand in diesem Unternehmen was er zusammen mit Schönbum 2008 gegründet hat. BSS-Booket
Share Services. So, kannst dir bei North Data alles anschauen, ja und jetzt ist also so ne, schön bum verlässt diesen Verein, weil
Lobbyvereinsmitgliedschaft lässt sich natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit seinem neuen Posten da verbinden und übergibt den an seinen Geschäftspartner, nein
ehemaligen Geschäftspartner, denn Schönbum verkauft auch seine Anteile an diesem Unternehmen und ist dann auch nicht mehr im,
Vorstand dieses dieses Unternehmens, ja? Also der musste natürlich für seinen neuen Job äh ein paar Sachen äh aufgeben und äh die hat die hat der,
Hans Wilhelm dünn dann eigentlich so ein bisschen schön weitergeführt.
Also schon sehr klar, was das für ein Verein ist, weil wenn du jetzt nämlich daran denkst, dass die die beiden den quasi gegründet haben
ja und damit ihr wirtschaftliches Interesse verfolgt haben, solche Vereine gibt es und ich sage mal so, die gibt es zuhauf.
Ja, das ist etwas, was in Deutschland, ich glaube auch, in vielen anderen Ländern üblich ist, dass man sich irgendwie, ja, im weitesten Sinne Interessenverbände,
äh Vereine und so weiter gründet, die dann irgendwie ne,
zum Schnittchen äh ähm Essen da sind oder dass man da mal Businessnetworking macht und so weiter und das ist,
muss man auch einfach sagen, ein bisschen auch der Grund gewesen, warum Arne Schönbumm überhaupt in in das BSI behoben wurde, ja.
Weil er ja Cyber-Präsident war.
Na ja, jemand, der wirtschaftsnah ist, netzwerken kann, ähm,
so ein freundliches Gesicht. Ja, ich meine, die der vorherige BSI-Präsident war jetzt nicht
ein Posterboy, ja also das war eher ich glaube der äh Physiker, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und ähm so den BSI BSI für Bürger, ne, einen umtriebigen Menschen da mal hinkriegen, keinerlei Ahnung von äh von der Materie,
was ihm zu Beginn seiner äh ähm seiner Karriere da,
auch oft vorgeworfen wurde, dieser Begriff Cyberclown stammt ja aus der Zeit, ja, dass man also sagte, komm, das ist irgendwie der Rentner mit so einem Lobbyverband rum, der hat keine Ahnung, wovon er redet und jetzt soll der ausgerechnet das BSI leiten, schwierig.
Allerdings ähm na ja komm mal komm mal nachher zu. Jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal weiter diesen Verein an. Ähm,
Also dünn übernimmt diesen Verein, weil der ja jetzt also wie gesagt diesen Witzverein und hält 20019 bei einer Tagung in Garmisch-Partenkirchen,
einen Vortrag und setzt sich in diesem Vortrag darauf dafür ein, dass Deutschland mehr Nähe zu Russland suchen soll,
man sollte, er zitiert irgendwelche Leute, die sagen, man würde Russland zu oft zu schnell verdächtigen, dass sie das gehackt haben, nur weil man mal ein Schriftzeichen irgendwo findet.
Irgendwie schon schon komisch genug ist, ja für ein Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland, aber wie gesagt, der kann ja reden, was er will, aber damit nicht genug. Am zweiten Tag unterzeichnet dieser,
Hans Wilhelm dünn eine irgendwie so einen Vertrag, so eine Absichtserklärung.
Mit Wladislaff Scherz, der diese Tagung in Garmisch-Partenkirchen äh organisiert hat,
da geht es um die Umsetzung von Beschlüssen des UN-Sicherheitsrates bezüglich der friedlichen Nutzung der Informationstechnologie.
Und jetzt fühlt sich dieser dünnen Berufen mit diesem Vladislaff Scherz.
Eine Absichtserklärung zu unterschreiben und zwar unterschreibt er die auf Englisch als Council und Cyber Security of Germany.
Macht also jetzt hier Verträge. Mit mit einem Russen und der unterschreibt das äh im Namen der russischen Organisation
NAIS, dem nationalen Verband für internationale Cybersicherheit. Das ist auch so eine ähnliche Organisation in diesem Fall gegründet von der,
äh staatlichen Universität in Moskau und ein paar anderen staatlichen Stellen.
Ist jetzt dieser.
Jahrzehnte lang KGB-Kader, Generaloperst AD und ähm war Generaldirektor des auf äh elektronische Überwachung spezialisierten Fabsi.
FAPSI ein Nachrichtendienst, der dann später in den FSB integriert wurde.
Der war also für die ab Abhöraktivitäten Russlands jahrzehntelang verantwortlich und ist natürlich mit staatlichen Stellen weiterhin sehr gut vernetzt. Äh,
So, also ich meine, was reitet also dieser Dünn scheint wirklich.
Vor allem was ich meine dieser Verein hat ja erstmal jetzt meine, der tut jetzt zwar in seinem Namen sehr staatstragend, aber ist ja erstmal nur ein scheiß Verein was was bringt das, dass er jetzt eine Absichtserklärung.
Vogel äh macht, also wozu?
Also es ist natürlich es waren damals und es war auch 20019 schon Thema, dass halt,
Also viel die deutschen Sicherheitsbehörden waren sich ziemlich sicher, dass diese Tagung eben einen nachrichtendienstlichen Hintergrund hatte, ja. Also,
dass es russische Stellen wahrscheinlich gemacht haben, um ihre Netzwerke auszubauen, ihren Einfluss auszuwerten mal zu gucken, was es da so für Unternehmen gibt, mal nachher einen Bericht zu schreiben, wie,
völlig bekloppt die alle sind oder nach wie viel nach wie viel Glas Wodka die anfangen noch mehr Unsinn zu reden, ne.
Oder auszupacken.
Oder so läuft das halt, ja? Also so läuft das ja auf solchen äh Verbandssitzungen oder so, ja? Aber ich meine, die sind dünn, dass der sich also dass der sich anschickt da irgendwas als Fedral
republik of Germany oder also nicht Federal Republik, aber Germany Cyber Accounts sind irgendwas zu unterschreiben, vor allem,
Was erwartet er denn jetzt, ja? Also ich meine, kommt dann kommen die Russen nach Hause und sagen, wir haben einen Friedensvertrag mit dem Cybersicherheitsrat oder was? Totaler Quatsch, ja.
Ja vor allem was versprechen sich die Russen davon? Also ich meine sie wissen doch zumindest mit wem sie's zu tun haben.
Totaler, also der der scheint da wirklich äh also relativ der Name ist Programm.
Ich frage mich nur, ob der sich jetzt sozusagen damit selber aufwerten möchte, also was was für einen Zweck hat denn so eine Erklärung.
Fragt also ich glaube wenn du den heute fragen würdest, falls der das selber nicht er wurde ja zwanzig19 damit auch konfrontiert ähm und hat dann so ungefähr dazu gesagt, dass äh,
Ja, eher mit mit allen relevanten Akteuren spricht in seiner Rolle äh als äh Präsident des Cybersicherheitsrates.
Und total lustig, wie so ein.
Mhm.
Na ja und er hat Russland schmiert ihm dann auch noch weiter so ein bisschen Honig um ums Maul. Er war nicht zum Beispiel Wahlbeobachter in Russland.
Wirklich hat er was.
Ja, auf Einladung, auf Einladung des russischen Parlaments, war der da, ja?
Der Duma ähm nicht etwa als Mitglied der OSZE Delegation. Ja also es gibt Wahlbeobachter in Russland, ja, die werden aber dann von der OSZE dahin geschickt und es gibt halt,
Die Wahlbeobachter in Russland EV. So und da sind halt.
Man gründet jetzt einfach zu allem den passenden Verein.
Nee, aber ich habe das ja so die waren da waren Leute von der FPÖ von der AF
D, also FPÖ sind die Faschisten in Österreich. AFD sind die Faschisten in Deutschland. Frau National sind die Faschisten in Frankreich, Lega Nord und Forza sind die Faschisten in äh Italien und das ist doch die äh UK Independence Party, ne? Also,
Vollidioten in in.
Das sind die Faschisten in Großbritannien.
So ja äh und alle EU-kritisch und Russland positiv,
Mit denen war der dann da, ne? Die wurden halt dann war außerdem noch 2018rühmte äh also im äh später im gleichen Jahr, ne also ähm Wahlbeobachter in Simbabwe,
für für die Associaion for free Research and International Corporation, Afrik, äh die eben auch als mit russischen,
Propagandaspezialisten äh eng verwoben gilt. So, jetzt passiert zwanzig neunzehn.
Deckkontraste diesen ganzen Kram auf, ja? Das ist alles Wasser unter der Brücke von zwanzig neunzehn.
Also Russland, Russland positiv klingt ja so ein bisschen wie ne? Ich freue mich, ob's da auch eine passende App gibt. Äh nicht so die die Russland-Warn-App.
Das kommt gleich,
Jetzt gibt's zwanzig neunzehn, also schon Kontraste Zeit setzt sich damit auseinandersagen, da da rennt irgendwie so ein Vogel rum, der unterschreibt irgendwie Verträge mit mit Russen, was ist das für einer?
Ja? Konfrontieren den. Er sagt hier nein, ich mache hier
äh mit allen relevanten Akteuren und so weiter. Was ja auch von mir aus also kann ja erstmal so machen
ja als Wirtschafts äh Interessenvertreter ist das ja durchaus auch ähm.
Osus, ja, dass man mit allen relevanten Akteuren versucht, Geschäfte.
Er hat sich nicht mit dem Bundeskanzleramt EV abgesprochen.
Der Feinstaub war schon weg. Also es äh wirklich absolute Witzfigur ne, aber nochmal ne, diese
dieser Verein, der ist ein Witz seit seiner Gründung und das war ja nun mal schon bekannt als Schönbum äh BSI-Präsident war, war wahrscheinlich sogar seine also sein Ticket, ja.
So jetzt äh Konsequenz
über diesen von diesem Bericht zwanzig neunzehn. Ich weiß nicht, wann genau das äh passiert ist, aber Schönwumm hat dann seinen Mitarbeitern im BSI die Weisung erteilt
dass sie mit dem Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland EV keine öffentlichen Auftritte abliefern sollen. Also distanziert sich schon davon, ja? Ähm,
gewissermaßen, also nachdem er eben sieht, dass sein ehemaliger Geschäftspartner ähm ein bisschen,
ja zu viel Vodka getrunken hat. So,
Aber da ist wie gesagt aus diesem Verein schon längst raus, hä? So, jetzt tritt in diesen Verein, was ein Lobbyverein ist, ja, wo die natürlich auch über jedes Mitglied,
wahrscheinlich zufrieden sind, weil jedes Mitglied musste wahrscheinlich irgendeine Form von Mitgliedsbeitrag zahlen und,
stärkt natürlich durch die Anzahl der Mitglieder den den den Wert dieses Vereines, ja oder auch diese Bedeutung dieses Vereines und da tritt ein,
die Protheon GmbH.
Und zwar im Juni zwanzig 20. Ja, Juni 2020 vor also etwas mehr als zwei Jahren tritt die Protheon GmbH in diesem Verein ein,
weiß leider jetzt gar nicht ganz genau, wie viele Mitglieder dieser Verein hat, aber es werden wahrscheinlich nicht wenige sein. Äh das haben wir Sicherheitsrat,
DE oder was?
Da kommt eine HTDP oh.
Mitgliederliste haben die, glaube ich, so gar nicht, oder?
Über uns Mitgliedschaft.
Vorteile Mitgliedschaft. Ne also guck mal hier, das sieht man. Vorteile an Mitgliedschaft. Erster Vorteil, Zugang zum Vereinsnetzwerk inklusive Entscheidungsträgern aus Politik, Wirtschaft, Wissenschaft und Gesellschaft, ne? Also ganz,
Ganz klar, Einbindung in das internationale Netzwerk bestehend aus Köpfen der Cyber-Community.
Siehst schon Bescheid, ne? Und dann wird's den Leiter des Präsidialbüros, das also die haben sich da, glaube ich, irgendwie echt,
Total Quatsch irgendwie aufgezogen, können sich aber offenbar sogar ein,
eine Adresse in äh Columbia in den USA leisten. Ja in Moskau haben sie keine.
Es gibt übrigens eine äh Mitgliederübersicht des Cybersicherheitsrats Deutschland. Komischerweise aber nicht mehr auf der aktuellen Webseite, wohl aber noch im Google cash?
Aha.
Ich zähle mal so grob durch. Das sind immer so hier vier brutale, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben,
achten,
Neunzehn, elf, zwölf. Das ist gar nicht so uninteressant. Ich lese mal vor, einfach die Namen hier, die meisten kenne ich nicht, Abartis Akronis AIG an Kura, Assikor, Aurasec, also so diverse Buden.
Avira Avenga, solche Start-Up Namen. Bayer AG, BDO, Bernsteingruppe und Bird Black Net.
Bis jetzt erst bei Betim, ne? Das geht noch ein.
Ja äh wo du's sagst, aber jetzt wird's schon interessant hier.
Irgendwann kommt ja C, dann kommen die ganzen Cyber.
Jetzt kommt doch erstmal Botschaft von Spanien, dann kommt, ich springe mal ein paar Bundesministerium für Gesundheit.
Äh Kobalt, habe ich doch auch schon mal gehört. Commerzbank Kontinental, ich lese jetzt mal nur die vor, die ich so ein bisschen kenne, aber jetzt ähm liefert leider der Cash äh nicht mehr. Sorry, also das geht hier wie.
Okay, also doch schon relativ viele, ne?
Ja, also wenn das bis D schon 16 sind, dann ist die Liste lang. Mhm.
Aufnahmebeitrag 1000 Euro Jahresbeitrag zweieinhalb, wenn ihr jetzt die Liste ist lang, dann weiß ja der Film hat äh der der Verein hat äh relativ viel,
relativ viel Möglichkeiten, ja. Aber okay, jetzt jetzt und zu diesen Mitgliedern des Vereines, die also zweieinhalbtausend äh oder dreieinhalb im ersten Jahr und äh zweieinhalb für jedes Folgejahr zahlen, ist jetzt die Protheon GmbH,
und die ist Tochterunternehmen des russischen Cyber-Security-Unternehmens AOA Infotext.
Und die hieß auch vorher, Infotext GmbH hat sich nur umbenannt.
Und dieses Infotext wurde 1991 von Andre Cha Cha F gegründet.
Der hat zuvor ein Jahrzehnt in der Forschungsabteilung des KGB gearbeitet äh und hat äh dann,
äh irgendwie vor Kurzem vom Putin per Dekret, von Putin persönlich, den russischen Verdienstorden für das Vaterland verliehen bekommen, weil er eben 30 Jahren,
oder weil er zu 30 Jahren Tätigkeit von Infotext ja also das heißt irgendwie
ja vor vor kurzem ne, also wenn er 91 gegründet hat, hat er also irgendwie im Juni 221 für 30 Jahre Infotex
den Verdienstort für das Vaterland bekommen, nachdem er bevor er dieses Unternehmen gegründet hat beim KGB war. Kannst du jetzt auch ungefähr vorstellen
warum der diesen Orden bekommen hat, ne? Das ist jetzt selten, dass ein Präsident jemanden zum 30-jährigen Firmenjubiläum Verdienstorden
ähm kippt, ja,
und dieser äh KGB ehemalige KGB Offizier Andre Chapchie war,
auch in Deutschland der Chef von Infotext, bevor das Unternehmen dann 20022 in Protheon GmbH umbenannt wurde.
Dann gibt's natürlich Berichte äh der also muss man also jetzt nicht so viel Mühe für geben, der also Infotext beziehungsweise Proteine und enge Beziehungen zum russischen Geheimdienst unterstellt.
Und auf dem auf ihre russischen Webseite werben sie auch damit, dass sie Lizenzen von SFB, also dem russischen Geheimdienst und FST einer äh eher technischen Behörde nutzen,
So, also es ist relativ naheliegend, dass dieses Unternehmen ähm mit den Sicherheitsprodukten, die es ja vermarktet, irgendwie sehr eng mit Russland zusammenarbeitet.
Das steht uns deshalb auch unter Beobachtung des FBI. So jetzt.
Wann sind die dazu gekommen?
220 sind die da.
Mhm, jüngst.
Ja und jetzt sagt der dünn,
Ja, die haben sich in dem Verein nie nennenswert eingebracht. Kann mir auch vorstellen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das scheint mir jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein basisdemokratischer Verein zu sein, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, das ist eher so ein Verein äh wo du,
ähm bezahlst und äh.
Wirst du auch informiert und eingeladen, genau.
Den Veranstaltung gehst, ja? Nur noch auf zwei Veranstaltungen waren die ähm.
Und auch das ist jetzt nix Neues, ja? So und jetzt kommt das einzige Neue,
Was man jetzt, was Böhmermann jetzt bringt. Jetzt hat der Schönwurm ja eigentlich schon 20019 oder wann gesagt, Leute, im eigenen Haus, ne, haltet euch bitte von diesem Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland EV fern.
Nachdem der im Öffentlichen der Kritik war, weil der dünnen irgendwelche Sachen unterschreibt,
So und jetzt wird er aber wird dieser Verein 10 Jahre alt, den SchönoMair selber gegründet hat und,
Er wird dann angefragt, ob er denn nicht vielleicht eine Festrede äh halten könnte und jetzt ist das so, der ist da gar nicht unbedingt frei
in der Wahl oder ne, dass ob er das macht oder nicht, weil er ja auch eben von seiner Position schwer zu trennen ist und insbesondere es ist ja hier ein Lobbyverband, ne, also muss er sich das genehmigen lassen.
Und stellt also eine Anfrage an das Innenministerium, ob er denn da eine Festrede zum zehnjährigen Bestehen dieses Vereines halten darf.
Und diese äh dieser Antrag wird geprüft oder was auch immer und wird am Ende genehmigt von Staatssekretär Markus Richter, dem sogenannten Bundes-CIO.
So und jetzt geht er zu dieser Veranstaltung, hält wahrscheinlich einen freundlichen,
Vortrag und twittert dann äh so was wie herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Zehnjährigen lieber Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland EV,
Ihr erfüllt eine wichtige Funktion als Impulsgeber und Austauschplattform, um Awareness und Management Attention,
für das Thema Cybersicherheit zu schaffen. Habe mich gefreut die Kino zum zehnjährigen Jubiläum,
mit etwa 300 Teilnehmenden in Berlin halten zu dürfen. Ich wünsche dem Präsidium und den vielen Mitgliedern gutes Gelingen für die kommenden zehn Jahre und taggt außerdem noch Manuel Höferlin von der FDP, der auch
da ist. So und,
Das ist das Einzige, was was der Stimmung um sich hat zu Schulden kommen lassen seit,
2019 beziehungsweise seit Gründung dieses Vereines die was ich denke absolut nicht in Ordnung ist,
Nur genau dafür hat er ja also der Vater sich ja offenbar die Genehmigung von Markus Richter geben lassen. Jetzt wird,
Die Sendung macht natürlich äh also Böhmermann Style macht natürlich sehr viel Wind und sagt dann hier der Cyber-Clown ist ein Risiko für die deutschen kritischen Infrastrukturen und so weiter,
und also ich ich meine.
Also da ist nichts bei, was man nicht vorher wusste, ne, dass dieser Verein irgendwie fischig ist, war allen klar. Übrigens nach äh Medienbericht die einzigen, die damals 20019 ausgetreten sind,
oder von denen ich es weiß, es sind vielleicht noch andere ausgetreten, wann der Bund der deutschen Kriminalbeamten
ein bisschen zu heiß. Die haben sich überlegt, was? Nee. Äh wir treten aus in Reaktion auf diese Enthüllung von Kontraste und Zeit, die übrigens auch nicht ohne sind, ne. Nur jetzt ist halt die und natürlich hat Stimmung damit echt einfach mal ein sehr schlechtes
bewiesen, dass er überhaupt bei seinem ehemaligen Geschäftspartner und Gründungskumpel von diesem Verein zu zehnjährigen spricht, nachdem er weiß, dass dieser Laden,
problematisch ist, aber sag mal,
Also der ja ist Netzwerker, also net,
Netzwerker, kein Techniker, muss er für den Job aber auch nicht notwendigerweise sein, ja. Er hat sich aus den hat sein Haus machen lassen, aus den
aus den Entscheidungen da eher rausgehalten. Das ist ein klassischer Führungsstil. In der Regel sogar ein ziemlich guter, ja, weil wenn man sich da raushält, was die Leute machen, kommt vielleicht doch was Vernünftiges bei raus. Er sollte die äh Beziehung zur Industrie verbessern, hat er gemacht.
Kreis der Hoflieferanten der Bundesregierung ein bisschen erweitern, ansonsten das BSI nicht aussehen lassen, ist ihm alles ganz gut gelungen.
Ähm ich glaube, dass eins der einzige Fehltritt, der mir irgendwann mal aufgefallen ist, ist, dass er sich für Hackback ausgesprochen hatte, sonst fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts ein ja und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage.
Was ist denn.
Wenn der jetzt weggeht, wer wird ihn dann da hingesetzt? Ja, ich würde mir ja ähm ich meine, er war jetzt nicht bekannt dafür, die,
größte Widerborstigkeit gegenüber dem BMI zu zeigen,
Aber er hat immerhin äh schon so gezeigt, dass er für den Prozess nicht zu haben ist, weil Nobilis Equities ist das äh die die der Prozess, den die USA haben, wo sie sagen
dass sie von Fall zu Fall entscheiden ob ein Zero Day von dem sie Kenntnis erhalten ähm öffentlich,
also ne, einer zugefügt wird, zugefügt wird oder.
Ob man das geheim hält, um es selber offensiv zu nutzen. Und das ist,
nach unserer Erkenntnis mit dem BSI nicht zu machen, was übrigens wahrscheinlich auch der Grund ist, dass man diese Citis gegründet hat, ne, die äh Behörde, äh die die die illegale Behörde, die erstens illegales tut und zweitens,
also einfach die wurde ja einfach gegründet ohne dass es ein Gesetz dafür gibt, was diese Behörde tun soll,
Und die Frage ist halt jetzt, jetzt feiern alle, ne, so ha ha ha äh der Cyber-Clown ist weg und so.
Aber machen Sie nicht darüber Gedanken, wer als nächstes kommt. Wir haben gerade eine Innenministerin, die,
Ähm ähnlich fachfremd ist, sagen wir mal wie der wie der Arne Schönwurm und die,
Sich gerade insbesondere in Bereichen der IT-Sicherheit,
von den dort dafür Verantwortlichen echt auf der Nase herumtanzen lässt, insbesondere von Andreas Köhnen, der da sehr viel länger sitzt als Sie,
der damals übrigens als äh BSI-Chef äh ähm,
ja den Kürzeren gezogen hat, ja, äh hat glaube ich das falsche Parteibuch. Ähm und der,
oder die ich weiß gar nicht ob den Parteibuch hat aber auf jeden Fall die falsche Parteisympathie den haben sie damals nicht dahin gesetzt. Der wäre von der technischen Kompetenz her sicherlich keine äh schlechte Besetzung gewesen hatte, aber so ein bisschen blöde Vergangenheit beim BND
Und ähm sitze jetzt im Innenministerium und mache da,
ja, dem ist glaube ich inzwischen oder dem scheint im Moment relativ egal zu sein, wer unter ihm äh Innenministerin ist, ja und,
Ich denke mir, dass der relativ,
klar für so ein ist und dass der sich sicherlich auch schon eine Liste hat an Leuten, die er gerne lieber an der BSI Stelle hätte äh oder an der BSI-Spitze hätte, als den Anne Schönbum.
Insofern ähm bin ich gerade nicht so unbedingt an dem Punkt, dass ich jetzt sage,
Ich freue mich jetzt dadrüber, was da gerade passiert. Hört klar, das BSI hätte sicherlich einen noch kompetenteren Präsidenten haben können. Das BSI hätte sicherlich einen,
ja noch mutigeren Präsidenten haben können,
diese ganze Clowns-Vereine und so, das hätte halt damals schon bestraft werden müssen, als man diesen Posten vergeben hat. Ja, aber jetzt irgendwie zehn Jahre existiert dieser Verein,
mit einem ehemaligen Geschäftspartner vom dann BSI-Präsidenten und all diesen komischen ähm diesen komischen Verbindungen,
dann jetzt nur für diese Rede, die man ihm genehmigt hat, ihn jetzt feuern zu wollen. Finde ich ein bisschen schwierig. Da müsste man mindestens den Markus Richter noch direkt mitfeuern.
Und da würden sich glaube ich mehr Leute freuen. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ähm insofern tja.
Kannst du noch mal sagen, welche Rolle dieser Andreas Köhnen spielt? Also der ist Abteilungsleiter.
Der spielt aktuell gar keine Rolle. Ja, also der spielt in der in der offiziellen in diesem Fall keine Rolle. Aber wenn ähm ein neuer BSI-Chef bestellt wird,
dann kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, äh dass der Andreas Köhn da äh durchaus mitspricht.
Also welche Abteilung leitet er denn.
Dass wir kurz schauen.
Also Andreas Köhn ist Abteilungsleiter im Bundesministerium des Innern für Bau und Heimat. Der vor war ja ministeriaal Dirigent im Innenministerium. Davor war er Vizepräsident des BSI.
Und ähm ich will den jetzt auch gar nicht hier persönlich so
hervorzerren, ja? Ich weiß nur, dass Azubi sowas wie das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 1 und zwei, das waren so seine Gesetze. Hatte ich, glaube ich, auch damals erzählt, dass ähm,
er damals bei der Anhörung zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei war er da, obwohl es sein Geburtstag war,
Ja, er hatte da äh quasi noch so was wollte sich dann da an seinem Geburtstag noch die Anhörung im Bundestag anschauen von seinem Gesetz. Ja und äh das ist technisch äh durchaus ein kompetenter äh Mensch.
Politisch äh stimme ich mit ihm jetzt nicht bei allem überein. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde ja jetzt gar nicht am Ende benennt den nächsten BSI-Chef, also erstens.
Ich hab's gefunden. Er ist Abteilungsleiter CI für Cyber- und IT-Sicherheit.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, genau. Der ist das ist also er ist wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, ist er eigentlich dem ähm.
Dem äh Schönbum vorgesetzt.
Das war die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man ihm das damals äh wie man damals mit ihm umgehen könnte. Er war ja BSI-Fize war quasi,
ja in einer guten da jetzt dann auch der Präsident zu werden und man musste ihm dann nachher irgendwie so einen Trostpreis geben und dann hat man gesagt, Kollege ist halt der Vorgesetzte von dem.
Insofern also nach meinem Verständnis sitzt er könnt,
quasi höher als der ähm als der.
Weil das BSI halt nach wie vor den BMI.
Unterstellt ist, genau. Außerdem war Herr Köhn von 88 bis 2006 beim Bundesnachrichtendienst beschäftigt. Und äh unter anderem hatte er dort den Posten des Sachgebietsleiters im Leitungsstab des BND-Präsidenten in Berlin.
Aber wie gesagt, ich will jetzt gar nicht so viel auf äh Andreas Köhn rumreiten.
Den Namen mal klarstellen, ne.
Ein neuer BSI-Chef, wenn ein neuer BSI-Chef bestellt werden sollte, ja, wenn Sie einen Weg finden, den Schönbomben loszuwerden und ich habe ich habe das auch schon getwittert, ich glaube,
ähm rechtssicher wirst du den dafür nicht los. Also da müsste den musst du den Markus Richter mitgehen lassen, ja? Weil der,
sicherlich wird der wird der äh gerade mit einem Zeltchen oder einer E-Mail wo ihm der Vortrag genehmigt wurde äh sitzen und sagen Leute was wollt ihr? Ja?
Und das in irgendein Lobbyverein äh alle möglichen komischen Unternehmen sind und netzwerken wollen, ist auch klar. Also ich denke, da echt so leid es mir tut, aber ich glaube, daraus kann man sehr schwer eine äh Versetzung,
Versetzung weiß ich nicht, aber irgendeine Form von Bestrafung ableiten, ja und wie gesagt mal ich habe eher Sorge, wenn hm.
Das also Nancy Phaser wird da keine informierte Entscheidung treffen,
und der Zuständige diese Position derjenige, der wahrscheinlich die Shortlist sich dann da zusammenstellt, ist auf jeden Fall Köhnen.
Und was der würde sich jetzt wahrscheinlich da jemand anders hinsetzen, ja? Politisch ein bisschen flexibler. Wie gesagt, der der Schönwurm war da jetzt auch nicht der harte Typ, der für das BSI gekämpft hat, ne, aber der hat eben schon sich vorm eigenen Haus grob sagen lassen, weil,
wie wie weit er wie weit er sich weich kochen lassen kann.
Also ich meine, das ist,
Also um's noch mal so zusammenzufassen, es gibt halt da irgendwie diesen Verein, der irgendwie eine Lobbygruppe ist, die irgendwie auf Cyber machen, sich genauso nennen wie so eine Bundesbehörde,
und äh der Typ, der den Laden gründet, wird dann irgendwann Chef vom BSI,
aber im Prinzip alle seine Verbindungen nach äh in diese Vergangenheit so und äh ist nicht mehr in irgendetwas beteiligt und ist auch kein mehr, weil sie aber dann auch Mitglied war, wahrscheinlich.
Das weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Es kann sein, dass da sozusagen wirklich nur nur Organisationen Mitglied sind, nicht einzelne Personen, aber das weiß ich natürlich nicht. Gehen wir mal davon aus.
Machen wir uns aber nix vor. Das ist sein ehemaliger Geschäftspartner, mit dem er diesen Verein jetzt zusammen gegründet hat, der vorher der Vize war, na ja.
Ja klar, das ist natürlich schon irgendwie fischig, aber ich meine, so sind halt irgendwie viele dann auch äh miteinander verbunden und sicherlich ist das jetzt irgendwie auch nix Neues. Nur jetzt, wo halt Böhmermann irgendwie mit dieser Story rauskommt und ihnen im Prinzip,
vorwirft, dass er einen Vortrag gehalten hat zu einer Zehn-Jahres-Feier,
Und das Schlimme da dran ist sozusagen, die Mitgliedschaft eines russischen Unternehmens, die aber erst eingetreten sind, nachdem er da weg war.
Ja, das Schlimme sind ja zwei Dinge: erstens, dass der dünn offenbar äh ne also der scheint wirklich nicht ganz,
knusper zu sein mit dem, was er da macht so, ne hm und das aber schon seit 20019 und da sehen wir auch seit 20019 bekannt und deswegen hat sie ja Schönbum selber,
die ähm die Order damals rausgegeben, mit denen lieber nix mehr zu
zuzusehen, dass man sich von denen distanziert. Und gegen diese eigene Order verstößt er jetzt eben ein paar Jahre später zu dem Zehnjährigen,
dieses Vereins mit der Rede, mit dem Keynote zum zum Jubiläum.
Was er sich aber hat genehmigen lassen und was ja jetzt sagen wir mal irgendwie auch na ja okay also ich meine,
So eine Rede da, fünf Minuten. Also.
Ich also ich finde jetzt nur sozusagen diese Reaktion auf diesen Burgermann-Bericht von vom BMI finde ich halt irgendwie so oh hoppala.
Mit Russland ähm obwohl es die ganze Story irgendwie so richtig keinen kein Fleisch hat.
Ja, das ist wirklich und wenn ich jetzt mal, ich meine, keine Ahnung, weißt du, kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen, was ich so was für Nachrichten kriegt, ne? Und also ich denke, der Stimmung ist jetzt ruiniert.
Und es ist schon ziemlich also.
Politisch demontiert, sagen wir es mal.
Ja politisch demontiert, so der von dem Rufschaden wird er sich nicht erholen und ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ne, also ja so,
Nochmal, der Verein ist ein absoluter Clownsverein, den überhaupt gegründet zu haben, ist in meinen Augen schon ein eine schwerer Fehler, der ihn auch für die BSI-Präsidentschaft vollständig disqualifiziert hat.
Die haben ja genau jemanden gesucht, der wirtschaftliche Netzwerke hat. Ja, sie wollten ja so jemanden haben, also haben sie den auch bekommen und ähm,
Tja, also ich äh ich denke, wie gesagt, das Einzige, was Sie eben theoretisch vorwerfen könnten, wäre dieser Vortrag und den haben Sie ihm selber genehmigt, also weiß ich nicht, äh mit welcher Begründung man denen jetzt äh rauswerfen will.
Kann ich mir keinen mehr beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen.
Das ist ja der Sohn von dem Jörg Schönbogen.
Ja, das ist auch noch ein Grund, den loszuwerden, aber der war der auch schon immer.
Dieser CDU äh Hardliner da.
Tja.
Also ich find's wirklich es ist ja ich glaube äh nicht das ist nix ja also wie gesagt ich werde mich jetzt hier nicht ähm.
So
Ich es gibt auf jeden Fall bessere Besetzungen für dieses Amt, ja, aber ich bin mir nicht unbedingt sicher, dass jetzt unter Nancy Phaser und ähm Andreas Köhn eine bessere Besetzung gefunden wird.
Warten wir's mal ab.
Und,
bin auch mal gespannt, ob sie nicht am Ende hingehen müssen, wohl oder übel und sagen müssen, na ja, der hat sich nix zu Schulden kommen lassen.
Dann können sie halt nochmal den den können sie vielleicht nochmal den den Shitsonstrahl auf diesen Cybersicherheitsrad lenken, wo er auch hingehört. Wie gesagt absoluter Witz der Laden.
Aber ich also ich glaube, wenn ich da jetzt an seiner Stelle irgendwie in unehrenhaft entlassen würde oder so was oder in irgendeine,
in irgendeine ins Archiv versetzt würde oder so was, ja, dann würde ich äh mich rechtlich dagegen zur Wehr setzen.
Also ich meine, ist ja auch sehr ungewöhnlich, dass jetzt sozusagen dann auch so in die Nachrichten zu kolportieren, ohne jetzt auch gleich einen klaren Plan zu haben. Also ich meine, normalerweise, wenn man irgendwie so eine Versetzung ähm durchsetzen möchte, dann weiß man auch schon.
Wer dann diese Rolle übernimmt. Also da da fehlt mir so ein bisschen auch die klare Kommunikation von Anfang,
bis Ende,
Hier es gab diesen Bericht, wir haben uns das mal angeschaut. Dieser Aspekt gefällt uns nicht, deswegen denken wir, diese Person ist nicht mehr tragbar. Deswegen haben wir jetzt folgende Maßnahme konkret,
auch eingeleitet und führen die jetzt auch bereits durch.
Also aktueller Stand ist ja, wir prüfen das und werden dann die notwendigen Konsequenzen ziehen.
Aber warum äußert man sich dann zu diesem Zeitpunkt denn überhaupt.
Äh äh ja weil man gefragt wird, ne? Aber äh ich glaube für warte mal,
Für diese Woche müsst ihr doch gewesen sein, war ähm BSI-Lagebericht. Das ist ja das große Ding. Einmal im Jahr,
bis ihr Lagebericht, ne? Da wird die Lage des Cybersicherheit in Deutschland berichtet. Das ist äh was weiß ich, 50 bis 80 Seiten oder sowas, ja.
Und dann äh fassen so ein paar Fälle zusammen und dann wird immer gesagt, yes unverändert Scheiße oder so was, ne und dann meistens äh äh werde ich dann auch noch in die Tagesschau oder Tagesthemen bestellt und muss da was zu sagen.
Und das äh war auf jeden Fall für diese Woche angekündigt und dieser Termin wurde, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe,
abgesagt.
Wurde er. Äh lässt man sich echt, ja, das ist echt interessant. Bömmermann übernimmt jetzt hier die Rolle des Spiegel.
Ja also ich ich sage ich,
Eher Sorge, wer da als nächstes kommt, weil da muss, da müssen jetzt, ja, muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen. Da müssen jetzt,
äh Digitalpolitikerin bei Grüne, FDP ähm,
die ja an der Regierung beteiligt sind, echt aufpassen das nennt sie Phaser da jetzt nicht irgendeinen aus der ne von der Liste holt,
der äh super aussieht und ähm dann aber am Ende eben nicht für einen unabhängigeres BSI eintritt,
eben auch das Ziel war, ja und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir leben hier in einer äh wir leben hier gerade in einer Zeit,
wo wir über Chatkontrolle und Vorratsdatenspeicherung diskutieren, ne? Wir leben hier in einer Zeit, wo grade das BSI-Defit auch natürlich,
niemanden gefreut haben, ne? Diesem Gematikvorschlag äh die Zustimmung versagt hat, genau oder versagen wird genauso wie der äh äh Bundes äh Beauftragte für.
Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit. So,
der ist jetzt weit davon entfernt ein großartig unbequemer Typ zu sein, ne? Aber am Ende muss man einfach sagen, hat er hier was,
richtig übel falsch gemacht und da ist äh kann man muss man sagen ja hat er, aber das halt schon vor vor mehr als zehn Jahren oder vor vor zehn Jahren.
Und äh wenn man ihn da wenn man ihm das damals nicht zur Last gelegt hat, dann kann man's auch heute nicht machen.
Aus,
Na ja, gucken wir mal, wer da demnächst äh auserkoren wird und wie äh die Busse noch weitergeht. Ich habe so den Eindruck, da kommt noch irgendwie noch mehr Fleisch für uns zum Kichern.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ja? Und die sind also dann sollte man natürlich wirklich auf zusehen, dass man die also dass man diesen Cybersicherheitsrat Deutschland EV jetzt echt mal abwickelt. Das ist ja das war schon immer wirklich ein absoluter Scherz.
Aber BSI Chef wäre das nicht was für dich?
Ja äh würde ich drüber nachdenken, ja, aber da müsste ich mir auch äh anschauen ich meine.
So beim Innenministerium beschäftigt zu werden. Also es wäre was für dich. Ich glaube, da wäre noch.
Würden mich ja jeden jeden Morgen untersuchen, was ich können wir mal in ihren Rucksack gucken?
Da also äh mir fällt auf jeden Fall ein Posten ein, den wärst du wahrscheinlich los.
Da solltest du dir gut überlegen.
Gut, aber wegen der Russlands Connections wär's halt ein bisschen haarig, ne?
Nee, ich denke nicht, dass also das halte ich auch für unwahrscheinlich, dass die äh dass sie, dass sie anrufen. Also ich habe jetzt hier bisher äh habe ich noch keinen Anruf bekommen, ja.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich. Da wird äh Union ja noch ein Meister. So dann gab's Knallbum ganz viel. Na ja, so laut wird's nicht gewesen sein, eher Schnipp Schnapp.
Ne
Also da da das ist jetzt auch wieder so ein Ding, ja? Also was? Äh drei Stunden lang Zugausfälle in.
Norddeutschland an Bahnhöfen, Hannover, Hamburg, Berlin haben die Leute rumgehangen, weil es halt irgendwie in dieser Ecke da oben dann da nicht mehr weiterging und der Grund war, dass,
erst in Herne, in NRW und dann am Kreuz in Berlin,
vorsätzlich zwei Glasfasern durchgeschnitten wurden. Ja, zunächst gegen zwei Uhr morgens bei Herne.
Da wurde ein Kabelschacht geöffnet, der mit einem schweren Betondeckel gesichert war und da sind sie dann runter und haben die,
Glasfaser durchgeschnitten. Wichtige Leitung für die interne Bahnkommunikation und am frühen Samstagmorgen,
dann bei Berlin Karo, die Backup-Glasfaser. Ja, weil diese Warnredundant, weil sie hatten also quasi für für den Fall, dass eine von denen kaputt geht, ging der Traffic dann durch die andere,
Und da wusste also jemand sehr genau,
Welche Kabel, welche Licht Lichtwellenleiter Sie durchschneiden müssen und wie Sie da dran kommen. Ähm,
dass diese beiden äh Glasfasern waren für das GSMR, das.
Äh Global System of Mobile Communication Rales,
sorry, ich wusste hier gerade ganz kurz neben mir, was GSM ist. Hey. Da muss ich aber kurz Sekunde nachdenken. Ähm GSMR, also ein.
GSM artiges System, also zellenbasiertes äh
nicht GSM-Art. Es ist einfach GSM, ja, ist also zellbasiertes Funknetz, wo dann so die Züge durchfahren können und die Kommunikation zwischen Zug und Infrastruktur findet darüber statt. Also irgendwie
erlaubte Geschwindigkeit, Signalzustände, Weichenzustände, so die ganze Telemetrie, die bei so einem bei so einer
Zugfahrt ähm im Rahmen der Sicherheit und Ordnung des Zugverkehrs anfällt. Ich weiß nicht, du hast doch auch mal so ein äh CRE-Überzug,
Sicherheit gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob der GSMR auch eine Rolle gespielt hat.
Kann sein, aber die Sendung war eigentlich nicht besonders gut. Die muss ich irgendwann nochmal neu machen,
aber äh auf jeden Fall ist GSMR halt eine ganz wichtige, grundlegende Infrastruktur
die halt jetzt sozusagen in den nächsten Jahren hin auf diesen europäischen Standard äh äh ETCS hin sozusagen auch äh abgelöst werden
wird. Insgesamt ist das Teil des sogenannten Rail-Traffic Management Systems,
tolle Abkürzung. Auf jeden Fall, wenn diese Glasfasern weg sind, dann funktioniert die Kommunikation oder in dem Fall mit diesen beiden Glasfasern, äh als die äh
wurden und da wusste wohl jemand auch gut Bescheid äh fiel eben einfach dieses System aus, weil einfach,
relevante Komponenten nicht mehr miteinander kommunizieren konnten, so dass eben die Betriebssicherheit nicht mehr garantiert werden konnte, woraufhin eben der.
Wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr Menschen gebraucht.
Fernverkehr, genau, da muss einfach der komplette da muss also so wirklich alles stehen bleiben und das das blieb es dann auch und dann war eben äh das Geschrei äh groß, ne, aber ähm,
Ja, das konnte dann auch wieder behoben werden und das sogar relativ fix.
In drei Stunden, also.
In drei Stunden hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht eine von den beiden Fasern spleißen können, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich kann das nicht so gut und äh also äh jetzt ist natürlich auch jetzt ist das Geschrei natürlich wieder groß, ne? Also.
Es war ein Anschlag auf eine kritische Infrastruktur Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Korrekt,
Es ist der Zweite in kurzer Folge, ja? Die haben uns äh oder irgendjemand äh hat ja einen Schaden an Nordstream eins und zwei herbeigeführt, so. Ähm,
großes also großes Hin und Her erstmal.
Also der Ausfall verhältnismäßig kurz, muss man einfach mal sagen, drei Stunden ist ziemlich kurz und.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, man soll die sollen bitte ihre Glasfasern besser schützen, ne? Die Deutsche Bahn hat so was wie 20.000 Kilometer Glasfaser.
Und klar, nicht alle davon sind so neuralgisch und zentral, dass ne, dass du, wenn du sie äh zerstörst,
eben das ganze GSMR ausfällt in einem großen Bereich der Bundesrepublik, aber zum Beispiel ne, mal die mal die Positiv-Aspekte. Es ist nicht in ganz Deutschland ausgefallen,
Es ist nur drei Stunden ausgefallen und die äh ich glaube Herne ist wahrscheinlich 5 600 Kilometer von Berlin, oder? Fünfhundert?
Ich gucke mal.
Müsste so fünf fünfhundert Kilometer sein, würde ich jetzt mal schätzen, ja.
Mitm ICE Herne hat keinen ICE-Bahnhof, aber.
Gut geschätzt, fünfhundert Kilometer, mhm.
So, ne, denn äh.
Also was willst du jetzt machen? Also ja, ist klar, musste machst du ein Schloss drauf, aber ich wüsste jetzt auch, also ich mir mir fällt es jetzt schwer,
Du könntest natürlich jetzt ein großes äh Überwachungs-Über besser äh mit Videos überwachen oder so, ne, dass da keiner drangeht, äh derartiges kann's natürlich tun.
Aber so.
Also jetzt hier nicht doof klingen, ne? Aber muss ja mal irgendwie sagen, okay, dann überwachen wir jetzt mal über, weiß ich nicht, wie viele ähm,
Wenn ihr einmal quer durch Deutschland, was ist das? Wahrscheinlich so.
Achthundert Kilometer oder sowas oder 900 Kilometer von Süden nach Norden dann quer durch, also müsstest du so ein paar hundert Kilometer oder ein paar tausend.
Kilometer musst du einfach kritische Fasern haben. Davon hast du zwei, die sie's ja hier haben. Ist ja, ist ja eigentlich schon mal sehr gut, ja und dann ähm.
Müsstest du die halt alle überwachen, ne, beziehungsweise da, wo sie aus der Erde kommen. Klar, kannst du jetzt Kameras hinstellen, aber an die
vielen Stellen kommen, die hilft dann auch nix, wenn die ganze Zeit die machen die Graffiti-Sprüher schon weg die Kameras, ja? Da müssen die müssen die äh äh.
Also um um festzustellen, dass ein Problem ist und das äh wo dieses Problem ist, kann man ja die Glasfasern auch selber benutzen. Man merkt das ja im Prinzip auch sofort, wenn diese durchtrennt wird.
Sind, ist ein.
Und man kann halt auch auf einer Glasfaser relativ schnell herausfinden, wo das Problem ist, indem man halt einfach einen längen äh Test
inwiefern so was existiert und äh also in automatisierter Form existiert entzieht sich meiner Kenntnis, aber das ist sozusagen schon,
machbar. Man kann jetzt schon, das heißt ja im Prinzip auch schon gesagt, aber man kann durchaus jetzt mal applaudieren, dass das sozusagen nur drei Stunden äh den gesamten Verkehr durcheinander gebracht hat und die eigentliche Frage ist ja, lässt sich das in irgendeiner Form
noch besser mittegieren, ja,
Sinne von äh entweder verhindern verhindern kann ja nur bedeuten, dass du den physikalischen Zugriff,
auf diese Infrastruktur noch weiter absicherst. Das ist natürlich jetzt bei diesen Mengen,
schwierig, also wie tief in die Erde sollen die denn jetzt gebuddelt äh werden, ja? Das macht ja dann auch die die Wartung äh schwieriger. Die mag auch teilweise unterirdisch liegen, das weiß ich gar nicht, ne? Aber ich vermute mal der
physische Zugriff jetzt auf diese Orte, wo dieser Angriff stattgefunden hat, war jetzt nicht total.
So, ne und wäre er äh es gewesen, hätte es vielleicht auch noch andere Orte gegeben, wo man im Prinzip denselben Schaden hätte,
ähm herstellen könnt. Was ja auch interessant, es ging ja auch gar nicht um eine totale Zerstörung, weil dann wäre ja, sagen wir mal.
Eine Bombe.
Zum Beispiel sehr viel nachhaltiger gewesen, weil ich glaube nicht, dass ich das dann so ohne Weiteres in drei Stunden hätte fixen lassen können, weil wenn es tatsächlich nur das neue Spleißen einer Glasfaser ist, wie du das vorhin gesagt hast, na ja, dann ist das,
Das ist ja auch komplexer, also in der Regel fallen ja dann eben auch Systeme aus. Wir haben das ja oft
besprochen, wenn's um diese ganze ne Absicherung von deinen äh Daten, deinen deinen Firmennetzen, dass du irgendwie nach einem Angriff hier äh von irgendwelchen äh deinen Betrieb wieder hochfahren kannst. Das sind ja alles Prozesse, die sollten eben vorher auch schon mal,
worden sein und äh geübt worden sein und äh gerade bei der Bahn entstehen ja auch,
eine Menge Folgeverluste, ne, weil du ja dann sozusagen diese ganzen Ausfälle, die daraus entstehen, ja dann auch wieder die die Sachen durcheinander,
Na ja, also insofern ähm sehen wir nur jetzt natürlich,
grundsätzlich die Verwundbarkeit solcher Systeme. Ne, wir haben hochkomplexe Systeme,
um unsere hochkomplexe Infrastruktur auch effizient betreiben zu können und überall da, wo es hochkomplex wird.
Äh entsteht natürlich auch also vergrößert sich die Angriffsfläche ganz automatisch.
Ja und ich also ich meine ich habe ich sehe das jetzt du hast wahrscheinlich noch sehr viele andere Punkte. Was worüber will man sich natürlich mal Gedanken machen sollte ist.
Muss man ja doch erstmal wissen. Und die größere Sorge, die ich mir eigentlich mache, ist, hm woher weiß das jemand, ja,
Sie sich also eine Gruppierung, sei sie jetzt politisch oder also vielleicht sogar militärisch motiviert, ja.
Woher wissen Sie das?
Also ne und woher woher wissen sie es vor allem auch so genau, dass sie wirklich sagen, okay pass auf da und da müssen wir hin, ja und diese Zeit irgendwie äh Samstag also zwei Uhr nachts in Herne, Samstagmorgen in Berlin,
ja sogar auch so ein bisschen darauf hin, dass dazwischen eine Autofahrt lag, ja sonst hättest du das an an beiden Stellen gleichzeitig gemacht,
Also das ist alles schon so ein bisschen,
Größere macht mir eher größere Sorge wie wie verbreitet dieses Wissen ist. Gleichzeitig hat die Bahn wahrscheinlich eine riesige IT-Abteilung mit äh,
Unmengen an Menschen, die der Mike gearbeitet haben, weiter gearbeitet haben und so weiter ähm sodass wahrscheinlich dieses Wissen
auch in den äh wenn du dann noch irgendwelche externen Mitarbeiter und Consultans nimmst, dieses Wissen wahrscheinlich bei ein paar tausend Leuten ist, ja.
Also geheim halten kannst du das nicht.
Das würde auch keinen Sinn ergeben. Weil du dann im Zeitfall ja dann im Schadensfall noch weniger Leute hast, die irgendwie wissen, wie man das fixen soll.
Jetzt diskutieren sie, ja, äh wir müssen wir müssen unsere Unterseekabel besser schützen
Ja, viel Spaß. Die liegen tief im Wasser. Und die sind tausende Kilometer lang und wir müssen äh wir müssen unsere äh Gaspipeline besser schützen. Ich also,
tatsächlich, ich wüsste nicht wie. Ne? Also das ist ähm vielleicht haben da andere Leute bessere Ideen,
aber mir scheinen solche Dinge de facto ein bisschen,
ja unbeschützbar zu sein, ne? Vor allem jetzt kann man natürlich kritisieren, okay,
wenn das da wirklich reicht, dass man schwer ein Betonklotz beiseite hebt und dann mit der Zange die die Faser durchschneidet, ja oder mit der Flex. Ähm ja, das da könnte man sagen, da soll die soll die äh sollte die,
vielleicht ein bisschen höher liegen bei einer bei einer wirklich kritischen aber so.
Ja, das ist jetzt, dass ich, dass dass sich die Investition dann lohnt. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, also was halt wirklich absurd ist, ist so, dass es hier sozusagen keinen Bekennerschreiben gibt. Bahninfrastruktur war ja schon immer äh Ziel,
einer wie soll ich das nennen es gab so Gruppen, die meinten Bahninfrastruktur wäre ja böse weil.
Warum eigentlich?
Wegen Militärtransporten oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann dem auch nur begrenzt folgen, aber das ist ja jetzt nichts Neues oder Castor Transporte, die baden transportiert irgendwie,
Castoren und deswegen ist sie jetzt auch böse oder oder man will dem Staat schaden. Ich meine, schaden tut man hier einfach nur allen,
weil ich meine Bahninfrastruktur ist vielleicht mit, dass ja eine der,
wichtigsten gesamtgesellschaftlichen und auch der gesamten Gesellschaft äh nutzenden Infrastrukturen,
und äh wer dieser Infrastruktur schadet, schadet dieser Gesellschaft. Das heißt, es könnte eigentlich nur jemand ein Interesse haben, der entweder mit dieser Gesellschaft abgeschlossen hat oder ihr nicht angehört und ihr schaden möchte.
Nicht der Russe war's, aber ich meine das sind ja halt alles so Sachen nur wenn er sozusagen also auch kein politisches Bekenntnis entweder unmittelbar direkt verbunden ist,
kommuniziert wird oder sich daraus ablesen lässt, dann steht man ja danach auch irgendwie so ein bisschen da und dann ist es halt irgendwie so Kategorie Vandalismus, nur dass eben jetzt so ein gezielte Attacke an zwei Orten zeitversetzt,
genau die richtigen Kabel durchtrennen. Das ist halt auch nicht wirklich im eigentlichen Sinne Vandalismus.
Ja also okay du darfst natürlich nicht unbedingt nicht nicht alle Motivation des Terrorismus vergessen, ne? Dass man dass man äh einfach mal Ungewissheit, Angst und Diskussion schürt ist durchaus auch schon ein Ziel für sich
ja? Also dafür brauchst du keinen Bekennerschreiben.
Ja, das stimmt. Einfach eine allgemeine Unsicherheit, also doch.
Allgemeine Unsicherheit, ne. Also ich glaube der von ähm.
Davon leitet sich das auch sogar ab, ne? Terror von Furcht und Schrecken. Ja und dafür brauchst du nicht notwendigerweise eine ähm ja, nicht unbedingt ein Bekennerschreiben.
Bevor äh die Bahnnerds in die Kommentare einfallen, muss ich noch kurz sagen. Ich habe gerade gesagt, äh ECTS äh löst so.
Ich hab's gemerkt, du. Ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Ich wollte nicht wieder alles besser wissen, aber es das Train Management System gesagt hat, das ist aber Traink Control System.
Es gibt sowohl also das Managementsystem sozusagen der Überbegriff, da gehört das ECTS dazu, da gehört GSMR dazu und GSMR wird auch einen Nachfolger haben, aber das ist nicht ECTS, sondern das ist das Railway Mobile Communication System.
Franz.
Äh das haben die auch schon in auf ein paar hundert Kilometern, glaube.
Weiß da auch nicht viel drüber. Ich wollte jetzt nur bevor äh ne bevor jetzt wieder die weil ich meine man man,
Man kann schon mit dem Thema VPN eine ganze Menge Feedback auslösen, aber wenn's um Bahnen geht, weißt du, machen wir nochmal ein komplett neues Tor in eine andere Dimension auf. Deswegen beuge ich hier die ein bisschen vor, aber ist wahrscheinlich ohnehin schon zu spät.
Okay, da hast du recht. Also ich äh habe mich jetzt extra ein bisschen zurückgehalten zu einem möglichen GSM-Kram. Äh habe da ja beruflich ein bisschen mit zu tun. Aber ich,
Ich glaube, dass es auch relativ unerheblich, ja, dass es jetzt da irgendwie am Ende ein zellbasiertes Funksystem ist oder nicht. Ähm entscheidend ist es, war für die es war für die Sicherheit äh so entscheidend, dass,
Muss man auch sagen, die Züge werden ja gefahren. Nur die Bahn wollte den äh wollte quasi das Risiko nicht auf sich nehmen, die Dinger,
ohne dieses Sicherheitssystem befahren zu lassen. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch richtig so.
Ja, das ist halt einfach, da geht halt einfach nix mehr ohne GSMR.
Fährt der Zug nicht trotzdem? Also das weiß.
Kann er schon. Die Frage ist, ob er dann nicht zu nah anderen.
Einen anderen kommt,
Ja genau, also das äh diese ganzen Scherze mit, dass man eigentlich ja zwei Züge nicht entgegengesetzter äh Fahrtrichtung auf eine
auf ein Gleis setzen kann und so weiter, ne? Diese ganzen Sicherheitsmechanismen, die werden sicherlich zu großen Teilen darüber abgebildet, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Vermuten wir jetzt mal so ganz grob ohne Bahnnerds zu sein.
Ja, okay. Bahn-Nerds können das in den Kommentaren machen. Äh könnte auch sein, dass wir in der nächsten Sendung einen Bahnnerd dabei haben. Wer weiß? Ja, gibt ja die verrücktesten Dinge und ähm damit äh.
Ich war sogar auf einer Bahnmesse und habe keine Ahnung.
Ich bin schon mal mit der Bahn gefahren.
Ja. Wie hieß diese Messe trans? Gott, jetzt hast du wieder vergessen. Der war doch vor Kurzem erst.
Transrapidanz.
Nee, äh.
Diese wo ganz viele Trans heißt sie genau. Inno Trans 20022 aber hat mich nicht so umgehauen.
Ich muss sagen, ich meine, ich äh ich habe also auf auf auf die Gefahr, dass ich mich unbeliebt mache, ne. Ich fahre ja relativ viel Bahn.
Ähm aber ich kann nicht behaupten, dass mich.
Bahn in meinem Leben als Kind oder als Jugendlicher oder auch heute noch besonders fasziniert hätte. Also fast es fasziniert mich,
teilweise, wie scheiße die ist, aber so nee ähm ich also kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich diese ganzen Schienenverkehrsnerds so äh kann ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen. Also.
Warum, erklär's.
Na ja, ich meine zunächst einmal handelt es sich einfach bei der Bahn um ein hochkomplexes System, was einerseits schon sehr alt ist
ja, aber auch in gewisser Hinsicht Unglaubliches leistet.
Ne, sich einfach mal vorstellt, wie viele Züge in Deutschland oder überhaupt in der Welt, aber weil man mal vielleicht mit dem Fokus auf Deutschland. Wie viele Züge hier rumfahren. Und was die alle für Anforderungen erfüllen müssen, um täglich im Idealfall auf die Minute genau,
irgendein.
Zu stehen, das ist schon wirklich krass. Und allein schon so ähm mit Leute zu tun, das ist schon eine Weile her, die auch nur so diesen Aspekt-Fahrplan,
äh sozusagen als Thema hatten. Ja, also wie macht man überhaupt einen Fahrplan, das alles aufeinander abgestimmt ist? Das
das sozusagen für jeden immer ein Gleis frei ist, dass alles rechtzeitig kommt, dass da noch genug Luft,
drin ist, wenn irgendwas passiert und es passiert dir die ganze Zeit irgendwas. Heute ist mal das Wetter, dann sind wieder zwanzig Selbstmörder unterwegs. Also du musst ja mit mit allem Möglichen rechnen, aber dann eben auch noch diese ganze Generation an an Technologie, die ja dann langfristig eine Auswirkungen hat.
Das ist schon einfach extremer
Spaß und äh ich kann total verstehen, weil da da ist halt einfach sehr viel Komplexität zu beherrschen und sie wird ja auch recht,
beherrscht. So, das muss man ja mal sagen und ähm insofern habe ich da,
höchstes ähm höchsten Respekt auch davor und auch als auf dieser Innotrans rumgelaufen bin, auch wenn jetzt sagen wir mal für mich selbst nicht so viel dabei war, weil ich da nicht so äh drin war und alles worüber hätte ich mal ein bisschen schimpfen wollen, gab's irgendwie nicht die richtigen,
aber dann läufst du so durch so Hallen, die einfach voll sind mit einfach so Kram.
Ja, nee, aber auch so mit,
Teiltechnologie, ne? So, wir sind eine Firma für um, oh Gott, jetzt fahren wir keine guten Beispiele ein, aber so ganze halten die sich einfach mit äh
Prüfung und der technischen Sicherstellung, dass dieses und jenes und die Kabel und die
Puffer und die die Schienen, dass das alles richtig vermessen wird, dass das alles überwacht wird, ne,
ach ja genau und an einer Stelle hatte ich auch so einen richtig äh äh Nerd Gazm. Als ich irgendwie so ein auf so eine irische äh Firma gestoßen bin, die so mit Hochgeschwindigkeitskameras, vorbeifahrende Züge mit bis zu 300 Stundenkilometer
äh fotografiert und dabei in diesem Moment durch zwei Fotos äh diesen
Pantographen, also diesen Stromabnehmer des Zuges, dreidimensional vermisst und dann innerhalb von äh kürzester Zeit herausfindet, ob mit dem, was nicht in Ordnung ist.
Irgendwie abgenutzt ist, weißt du und solche Irre.
Ja das ist ja alles cool. Ich will ja jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass das nicht stimmt, aber äh das ist nicht dass da dass das nicht spannend ist, aber was oder dass es dass es jetzt langweilig wäre bei der Bahn zu arbeiten oder so, ne?
Ich verstehe nicht, warum ich mich in meiner Freizeit jetzt noch damit auseinandersetzen soll.
Weil weil du nicht so viel Freizeit hast, du musst dich ja die ganze Zeit mit Netzpolitik rumschlagen. Man kann ja auch nicht alles machen, aber.
Und IT-Sicherheit kann man ist ja tragisch scheiß genug. Also die Einzige, die einzige Bahn, die mich die die tatsächlich also ich bin ja schon welche Bahnen haben mich fasziniert. Ähm.
Also Schinkansen, pünktliche Bahn, faszinierend, äh das fand ich spitze. Ähm.
Das war's, Japan.
Du in der Schweiz kann man ja auch irgendwie aus.
In der Schweiz kann man ja in der Schweiz kann man auch seine Kosten kommen, ist aber zu voll,
weil die ihr GA, das ist ja nicht teuer genug, die ganzen da sind ja also alles voller Schweizer in der Bahn und äh das ist immer sehr voll in der Bahn in der Schweiz kann ich kann ich nicht anders sagen. Und äh ne USA
Also mit dem ähm mit dem ja die haben sehr bequeme Züge.
Und langsamer auch.
Langsam bequem, aber riesige Sessel drin. Also da kannst du dich mit diesen Melkscheemeln, die in der Deutschen Bahn stehen echt nicht nicht blicken lassen, ne, wenn ihr jetzt mal mit so einem schönen US-amerikanischen Zug,
Da sitzt sie schon bequem.
Okay, na gut.
Richtig schöne gepolsterte Sessel. Ähm,
Prager, Pragerbahn. Kannst ja manchmal Euro City fahren und so hier. Ähm gibt's ordentliches Essen, ist auch faszinierend.
Ja. Ja.
Schöne Farbe. Äh nee, aber so in Deutschland hält sich der Bahngenuss ja dann doch in Grenzen.
Schon okay, Pferd, ja Pferd. Pferd meistens.
Da gehen die persönlichen Meinungen dann sehr auseinander. Ich mag die Bahn und äh ich verstehe auch alle Baden Nerds.
Ich mag's ja auch. Ich wollte dir nur aber guck mal, jetzt das Flugzeug ist doch auch faszinierend.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich.
Kann gar nicht, ist schwerer als Luft. So, aber das da da verstehe ich, dass Leute sich damit auseinandersetzen, aber Leute ein ein Leben der Bahn widmen.
Das ist einfach man versteht nicht die Kings äh von allen, aber die haben meistens eine Berechtigung. Ich
aus meinem langen äh Podcaster Interview leben, kann ich dir äh eins äh sagen, es gibt eigentlich gar nichts, was uninteressant ist.
Absolut richtig. Ich wollte auch nicht sagen, dass Bahn uninteressant ist, ne. Ich ich verstehe also völlig klar. Ich kann mir auch zum Beispiel gut vorstellen äh da zu arbeiten oder so, ne? Das ist irgendwie faszinierend ist, weil man ja man hat eigentlich so ein perfektes System,
Jeden Tag kommt wat Neues, ne? Wirft sich einer auf die Schienen, dann äh ne schneidet einer ein Kabel durch
äh dann geht die Klimaanlage im IC nicht, weil 22 Grad ist, sodass da jeden Tag was, also da ist immer was los. Da ist auf jeden Fall spannend.
Das ist wie ein wie ich meine also ehrlich gesagt verstehe ich gar nicht, warum du da gar keine Begeisterung für ausbringen kannst, weil wenn man sozusagen auch
im Bereich des Netzwerk Traffics unterwegs ist und sieht, was da immer alles möglich ist, ja, auch aus Sicherheitsaspekten, das ist dann halt mit der Bahn auch so, ne, nur mit richtigen Stahl und Ross und und Wetter und äh all diesen Dingen.
Nee, also ist ist super. Vielleicht habe ich dafür einfach nicht genug äh nicht genug Zeit mehr im im oder nicht mehr genug Platz im Leben. Nicht.
Gespoilter digitaler.
Konsumiere das einfach. Ich konsumiere das einfach. Ich gehe da rein, setze mich hin, na ja komm an und mache mir überhaupt nichts überhaupt nichts Gedanken.
Gut, dann äh kommen wir doch vielleicht zu äh der Veranstaltung für die Leute, die jetzt sozusagen.
Stimmt, wir müssen ja noch was wir haben ja noch.
Teil im Digitalen mehr was anfangen können wobei auch Bahnnerds dort zu finden sind mit Sicherheit.
Da auf jeden Fall. Da haben wir doch auch schon, da wird geil. Ich bin mir auch sicher, dass ich auf Tim Congress den einen oder anderen Bahnvortrag äh schon gehört habe, ja.
Nicht nur zu Fahrplänen. Genau, es wird nämlich es wird es soll geben einen 37 Chaos Communication Kongress und es fühlt sich merkwürdig an, das zu sagen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Ja, es äh hört sich merkwürdig an, aber irgendwann muss man ja mit der Planung beginnen, also machen wir das jetzt und äh wir haben jetzt einen CFP veröffentlicht.
Partizipation heißt das.
Genau. Und da kann man also einreichen in den Tracks Politics Effics Society.
Security, Science, Hardware und Art and Beauty.
Ähm der CF ist jetzt geöffnet. Die Deadline für Einreichungen ist der 6. November,
Die Notifications of Exceptans kommen am 27. November und das ist dann eben ein Monat vor der Veranstaltung vom siebenundzwanzigsten,
30. Dezember. So, ich die Deadlines sind natürlich alle ein bisschen spät, ja? Ich glaube, das haben wir sonst äh früher hingekriegt oder hoffe ich zumindest. Hm,
Ich hoffe, das ist vielleicht für die Einreichenden verständlich, dass die Planung einer solchen Veranstaltung zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch mit marginalen Unwegbarkeiten verbunden ist
äh so dass wir eben das so spät machen. Ähm
aber da färbt ihr jetzt fast einen Monat Zeit euch über eine Einreichung Gedanken zu machen, natürlich euch auch potenziell darüber Gedanken zu machen, auch da gab es ja schon Fragen äh
dass es Leute gab, die vielleicht gerne etwas einreichen würden, aber sich nicht so sicher sind ob sie denn an Ort und Stelle sein können.
Aus verschiedensten Gründen. So was kann man natürlich bei einer Einreichung mit angeben, ne, spricht ja nichts gegen.
Da mal ein äh Häkchen zu setzen.
Der Kongress soll, das wurde ja auch schon mal kommuniziert, aber das kann man an dieser Stelle auch nochmal betonen. In Hamburg stattfinden,
er ja auch schon fünf Mal stattgefunden hat. Wenn ich mich jetzt nicht äh verzählt habe
und äh zwar vom 29 bis zum 33 C drei. Danach gab's ja den Umzug nach Leipzig. Jetzt soll der Kongress wieder zurückkehren nach Hamburg an denselben
Ort oder das Faszienselben Ort, der ist äh umgebaut worden, das CCH ist ja renoviert worden. Das war ja auch der Grund, warum wir da überhaupt weggegangen sind.
Ja und ähm,
Da sind wir alle sehr gespannt, weil das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass sich der Kongress nochmal in seiner ganzen Gestalt und Ausprägung ein weiteres Mal deutlich verändern wird. Abgesehen davon, dass er sich,
von Jahr zu Jahr immer weiter entwickelt hat, aber jetzt ist so eine Art big to the roots,
äh Effekt an der Stelle äh natürlich da. Es wird also nicht diese ausufernden Megaflächen wieder geben, wie man sie in Leipzig gesehen hat und wir sind da alle glaube ich sehr gespannt,
was daraus dann äh resultieren wird. Ich finde die Entscheidung trotzdem richtig. Das ist ein guter Ort. Hamburg Leipzig hatte seine Vorteile, aber auch seine,
Probleme und ähm in gewisser Hinsicht denke ich hatte auch der.
Dort in Hamburg seine bisher beste Zeit gehabt. So, ich denke, da hat irgendwie alles äh gepasst. Und jetzt müssen wir mal schauen,
wie sich der Kongress da zurechtgeruckelt bekommt mit den leichten Änderungen, die dort vorgenommen wurden. Also es gab da ein paar äh räumliche Veränderungen. Eintracht ist komplett neu aufgebaut worden. Gab,
paar zusätzliche äh Gänge, damit dort halt die Veranstaltungsflächen besser voneinander getrennt werden können, wenn da mehrere Veranstaltungen gleichzeitig stattfinden würden, nehmen natürlich das gesamte Gebäude ein und ja, müssen wir gucken.
Wie das so sein wird, aber bin da eigentlich ganz optimistisch, dass der alte Drive auch wieder kommt.
Ja, wird auf jeden Fall äh spannend.
Und genau, wer einreichen möchte, kann sich jetzt darüber Gedanken machen. Zum Beispiel den Vortrag über Bahnen.
Warum es alle Nerds interessieren muss? Genau, die Komplexität des Bahnsystems sind heute hätte ich gern. Den würde ich mir.
Will ja nicht sagen, dass nicht komplex wäre.
Nur nicht fasziniert. Nee, wir brauchen halt einen Vortrag, den du dir dann anguckst, wo.
Als Kind keine Modelleisenbahn gebaut. Ich hatte eine Benjamin Blümchenkassette mit Eisenbahn. Die fand ich ganz gut.
Schnuff, schnuff, schnuff die Eisenbahn. Wer will, wer will mit nach Glück.
Bildungsauftrag nicht erfüllt.
Der wollte.
Aber der konnte dich ja nicht mitreißen.
Benjamin Blümchen als Lokomotivführer hatte ich. War so. Mal gucken, ob's das noch gibt. Loco.
Du warst so so was stirbt aus und dann ist es nie wieder irgendwo zu finden, weiß doch wie die Welt ist.
Benjamin Blümchen DE,
Als Lokomotivführer Nummer vierunddreißig, dein 11 hat mit Viertüre gibt's auf gibt's auf CD.
Sechs Euro neunundvierzig, MC. Man geht man kann das noch auf Kassette kaufen. Geil. Oder als MP3, ich kaufe das jetzt als MP3, so.
An und dann gucken wir noch mal, wie sie so zum Bahnsystem stehst. Vielleicht.
Auf dem Bahnhof in Neudorf ist eine Dampflokausstellung. Die wollen sich Benjamin und Otto auch ans Haus schauen. Sie sind begeistert von dem wunderschönen alten Loks und steigen ein. Es ist jedoch ziemlich eng und da passiert es. Benjamin verhakt sich mit dem Rüssel in den Hebeln
und die Dampflokdampf mit ihnen davon. So sieht's aus. Wie das wohl ausgeht.
Ein Elefant im ja das höre ich mir jetzt an, das graue ich. Ich gucke mal nur schnell weiter. Ich habe das ja schon mal gekauft. Nee, ich ich habe das ja.
Also ich hatte die Kassette. Die habe ich.
Du forderst sozusagen nur deine dir zustehende Sicherheitskopie an.
Nee, das ist ein wie Spiel. Nee, muss ich kaufen.
Das heute nicht mehr. Man muss dann immer wieder bezahlen. Nach zehn Jahren ist alles vergessen.
Echt? Neben mir also Moment, wenn ich wenn ich die Kassette habe, meinst du nicht, dass ich das recht habe? Die.
Ich meine ist jetzt vollkommen unerheblich. Ich sage ja nur kennst doch die Welt.
Oh jetzt muss ich mich hier registrieren.
Mach das mal. Äh wir können ja in der Zwischenzeit schon mal tschüss sagen. Äh,
du weiter äh recherchierst. Das war hier eure Kurzausgabe vom Anfang der Woche und wie gesagt, wir äh werden demnächst noch was nachlegen. Deswegen heute mal sehr übersichtliche Themenvielfalt und äh wir erwarten eure Bahnkommentare und freuen uns schon drauf
äh dann hören wir uns in ein paar Tagen wieder.
Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.